another police officer who won't face
trial for killing yet another unarmed
black man this time in the case of NYPD
officer Daniel Pantaleo who killed Eric
garner with a banned chokehold move back
in July garner was approached by police
who suspected him of illegally selling
loose cigarettes agree the whole
incident was caught on camera and a
medical examiner ruled the death a
homicide despite that a Staten Island
jury decided not to indict the officer
who killed garner this is the second
case in less than two weeks where a
grand jury decided not to indict a
police officer Antonio French tweeted
this must end we cannot continue to have
an entire group of Americans who can be
killed without consequence or legal
recourse the question everyone is asking
is why does this keep happening well the
first thing to keep in mind is it's very
rare for a cop to even be charged with a
criminal offense police usually
investigate such killings themselves and
you can imagine how that goes but when
these cases do go to a grand jury
wealth it's easier to indict a ham
sandwich for all cases on a federal
level out of 160 2000 grand juries only
11 returns a non indictment so why then
is it so hard to indict a cop well grand
juries exclusively rely on the
prosecution to present the evidence that
would send a cop to court sounds like a
slam dunk right well not when
prosecutors traditionally worked close
with police officers on other cases and
might not want to get their friends in
trouble how about some more general
numbers on the rare occasion when cops
are charged with any type of misconduct
they're convicted half as often as the
general population and around 400 people
are killed by police every year but
that's actually not a reliable figure
because the federal government doesn't
keep a complete count another big issue
at play here is the police's use of
excessive force it's not against the law
for a police officer to shoot to kill if
they view someone as a threat so what
have they been saying is a threat Darren
Wilson described Michael Brown as
looking like a demon and kept stressing
how huge he was the officer who killed
12 year-old Tamir rice thought his toy
gun was
that he looked around 20 so if you're a
black guy does that mean you're
automatically a threat well they are 21
times more likely to be shot dead by
police than white guys the national
outrage over this is huge but where can
it go from here protesters to civil
rights leaders to President Obama
himself are calling to reform the police
and justice system when anybody in this
country is not being treated equally
under the law that's a problem and it's
my job as president to help solve it
one immediate step that's being taken is
to promote police accountability by
getting officers to wear body cameras
Obama just requested 263 million dollars
in funding for that and other police
training but that's not filling everyone
with optimism as clay Kane tweeted
unarmed men can be killed off camera or
on camera and still there's no
indictment badge guns can't save us if
that's the standard
[Music]